what's up ladies and gentlemen today's a
very exciting day for the Game of
Thrones community HBO just released an
official season 7 promo and I must admit
this one has me very very excited this
promo established a four main players
and power in Westeros we have the two
queens of the south and we have the two
kings in the north and their power
struggle is about to make things very
interesting during season seven Cersei
and Danny are literally next-door
neighbors at this point who are both
seemingly willing to fight to the death
for the same thing that Iron Throne in a
season 7 progresses the night king is
going to be knocking on the door of the
north and by door I mean that big-ass
wall because he's going to be coming for
what's his as well but he's gonna have
to get through Jon Snow in the North
first what I loved about this promo is
some of the things that had confirmed
for us because there was a lot of
speculation during the filming of season
7 and people were wondering if Daenerys
was gonna have her own throne on
Dragonstone ever since this photo was
leaked months ago but now those rumors
can be put to rest because it's
confirmed Daenerys will have our own
little throne room on Dragonstone and I
admit it does look badass plus this
promo really confirmed that winner is
here and not only here but it actually
will make it all the way down to King's
Landing by the end of next season I did
report on this a few months ago when
this photo was first leaked and it's
obvious that they are adding some snow
to the city and if you look at this
photo from another angle you can
actually see the Lannister banners
hanging so it's obviously King's Landing
I wasn't expecting snow to make it this
far south in season seven but when these
photos were first leaked I got very
excited because I knew that it actually
would so you can only imagine what the
conditions are going to be like in the
north they weren't kidding when they
said the tone of the show was going to
be much darker from here on out but the
most exciting thing from this promo was
what we got at the very end when we see
Cersei Lannister on the Iron Throne and
she exhales and you can see just how
cold the air actually is which is kind
of terrifying when you think of how
sunny of a location King's Landing has
always been now I'm wondering how right
old nan was and if that history is going
to repeat itself and we are gonna see
the White Walkers not only terrorizing
the north but making it this far south
this reminded me of the scene in the
three-eyed Ravens cave
when Mira noticed how cold brands breath
was and she knew in that moment that the
night king was right outside the cave
this makes you wonder how far south the
night king is we're going to actually
make it during season seven
because when Cersei exhales it does fade
right into the night Kings eye
now personally I don't think he's gonna
make it that far south during season
seven but I do think he's gonna make it
to the wall and knock it down
but either way this promo has me very
hyped for season seven and also very
nervous for the north because once that
night King comes through that wall it's
gonna be party time and until John is
able to unite the Seven Kingdoms they're
gonna have one hell of a fight on their
hands let's just hope Dany's dragons
survive long enough to beat these
[ __ ] into submission I'm also gonna
stick to my guns about the first teaser
I still think that was a nice dragon's
eye that first teaser was heavily dragon
themed and at the very end when they
only showed two dragons standing that
makes me think that one of them is gonna
die even though that blue I didn't have
a slit in it like a reptiles eye I still
think that it could be a dragon's eye
because it would be too obvious if they
added a slit to that eye and if you
noticed in this new promo from today
that actually showed some of the Night
Kings face and his eye looked nothing
like the last eye those are two
completely different pupils in my
opinion but I'll let all you guys be the
judge and if you think I'm wrong then
feel free to tear me apart in the
comment section either way comment
anyway and tell me what you thought
about this new promo how height did you
get for season 7 I know it got me very
hype and even more anxious for July to
get here thanks for watching this quick
video I just wanted to give you my
initial thoughts let me know what you
think about it and I'll see you down in
the comment section bye